[Music]
I'm used to giving my opinions and I'm
used to often getting stick for them
this week there whilst I debated
politics on a BBC show I had a whole new
reason why of you I had a problem with
me no it wasn't that he disagreed with
me it wasn't because he didn't like me
and it wasn't even because I'm a brick
Setia
it was purely and simply because he'd
caught sight of one of my tattoos and in
his own words he said he would struggle
to take the political opinion of anybody
with a tattoo seriously as a society we
focus on supporting many different
groups of people but it is a fact that
one group who are regularly overlooked
at the working class whether it is
accents tattoos education or even just
location the working class are often
dismissed discriminated against
suppressed and antagonized and this dear
viewers is something I firmly believe we
need to work on private viewing one day
of my tattoos but the one that this
particular guy found was this one it
says believe it's a new one I've only
got two but I'm very keen that's what we
don't know as wonders we don't know that
called the way you did that that was
superb
are you working class so this is an
interesting one because it depends what
one means by working class so for me
personally I think working class
represents your upbringing your values
your morals your outlet morals yeah I
did working-class moral as opposed to
looking laws what do I think to a
working class moral and value and
attitudes maybe might not be moral is
the right word got an attitude so I do
regard myself as values Museum yeah I
regard myself a working class person
because and I feel your work what yeah
yeah I do
you're a journalist and broadcaster
economic it's where you come from
yeah you can't move class it's not that
money
can you move because it's classes
economic uh it's about the society in
which you grew your geopoint by some
measures by some economic measures or
whatever people may regard me as the
middle class in my heart in my soul how
I self-identify somewhere else are the
debates about self identifying trans
women and stop you on and so right how I
self-identify are just on the anneristo
I don't think you need to self-identify
because I actually agree you are thank
you I don't think it's about how you
feel it's about actually for me about
the social conditions from whence you
came yeah and so I think you fit you fit
that test and you can't change college
you know I do think I do think we can I
think I think you can change class is
that your children's class becomes
different so for me I see myself as
absolutely working-class proudly working
towards but my life circumstances means
that any children that I have will be
middle class and so I think their
children is your children are the ones
that then identify with the sort of
increase in social mobility but what's
upsetting isn't it there is now this
chav stereotype yeah which has become
synonymous with the white working-class
not really obsessed me and I believe
television a lot for that because they
have characters like Vicky Pollard and
there's a very interesting you got poll
done a couple of years ago and long
people who work in television 70% of
them thought Vicky Pollard was an
accurate representation of working-class
people and that's
Little Britain character Vicky Pollard
TV shows in the 70 safeties are nice we
had lots of working class shows the
likely lads the rag trade L boy we loved
those characters but we didn't sneer at
them but we love them we were looking
for them and now when you see a working
class character portrayed on television
it's a person to be that's not I have a
confession to make
yeah I have a touch was it you that sent
me that sweet brother in tattooing us on
this okay it's on it's on my back it's
not visible so I wouldn't necessarily
face any work discrimination workplace
discrimination for I do think the
approach to tattoos is changing social
attitude
however mine's quite a heavy and serious
one so I think I probably get away with
it if people ask me why why well because
well it was right so as a prisoner of
conscience in Egypt what I did is I in
part to sort of say that this episode is
behind me I tattooed my prison number
against your tattoo is and I and I know
that they really do mean mean things to
people when we get them but I really
want to focus this conversation on that
we have conversations about we need to
get more women into top jobs we need to
get more diversity into top jobs when
you actually look the working class and
where they are in the pay the pay gap
between working etc and I ve got some of
these staff yes I do
I just made a quick point I think you
are absolutely right and the social
mobility Commission released a report
this week social mobility has stalled
again in this country I just said the
facts are from the social activism
people who are working-class background
up age 17 percent less than that
colleagues from the middle-class edges
turn and then I have one from the ons
which i think is back to your point
Michelle in terms of discrimination
against the working class only 10% of
people from working class backgrounds
make it into Britain's higher managerial
professional occupations I think without
question when we talk about diversity
they are the biggest
discriminated group in society exactly
and actually encompass so many different
ethnicities obviously white
working-class
see I cry where's the outcry because
we're talking about we don't have enough
women we don't have enough even - I
don't think I think the regs it has
brought this to the attention of the
elite in that it has to be addressed one
thing I would say because you're right
we do talk about racial representation
gender diversity and we don't often
think of white working-class males did
you do we've spoken about this fortune I
do say on my LBC shall I say that some
actually this concept of privilege if
you take something like Diana Baur and
you send her to the Clooney estate where
I went to school says sessile Jones in
West gif where there's a lot of council
estates I find it difficult to find that
that the white working-class male who
grew up on those estates is more
privileged and somebody like Diane
Abbott and so this notion of that it
will always be that the white male will
be the oppressor and the ethnic minority
will be is the oppressed it's flawed
yeah you know because they have an open
white working-class males when I say
they have an over-representation in
jails in education go to university beat
underemployment under education so that
you've touched on something that is
really important and we have spoken
about this before but actually requires
solidarity across you know the various
groups if you like yeah to sort of try
and help working-class value that the
middle class wouldn't have then
straight-talking yes how about that yes
well my keys God straight to let me tell
you something somebody whose were up in
a minute
let's say somebody ground grew up from
Casas thank you the thing that I valued
most about the community that I grew up
around was you knew what they thought
they were straight to the point when I
went into media oh my goodness all of
this dancing around a subject never been
honest about what you really read and
all that solidness of the verses have a
pride as well yeah that was very proud
of different things proud of just
getting from one week to the next that's
what it's about well yet when you're
living on the council a sec we all did
yeah you know you didn't know whether
your parents are gonna get to the
Mexican Avenue what or not so there was
a pride and having a job who's a famous
painting achievement and you becoming
whatever it was gonna be
I'll end this topic with Michelle thank
you and we are proudly working class and
you have a thing or two to learn there
cramp so feed the endless chafing but
enough about Nick sex life race which is
also much sex life again race pretty
highly on the pain scale Nick sex life
who knows all too well is twenty
six-year-old Haley Carruthers
Haley had nearly completed all of the
26.2 miles of the London Marathon on
Sunday when just as she was approaching
the finishing line her legs started
giving way rather than give up the brave
Brummie managed to crawl across the
finish line and even beat her personal
best time by three minutes once she put
her feet up Haley took to Twitter to say
today I learned how not to run a
marathon at least IP beed Haley running
26 miles in two and a half hours I'd say
you did a pretty good job yeah so but
inspiring us to get off the sofa you are
are straight you ready Walker
that's always what time for this week we
don't forgave you want to do it in the
debate just search for the pledge on
Facebook or Twitter and all new pledge
podcast is available to download from
iTunes now thanks for watching everyone
[Music]